una universidad ofrece un cierto curso
que los estudiantes pueden tomar de
manera presencial o en línea los
maestros del curso tenían curiosidad de
saber si existía una diferencia en la
tasa de aprobados entre las dos
modalidades los datos de un semestre
reciente mostraron que el 80% de los
estudiantes aprobaron en la modalidad
presencial y el 75% de los alumnos
aprobaron en la modalidad en línea los
maestros están dispuestos a tratar estos
datos como muestras representativas de
todos los estudiantes que pueden tomar
cada modalidad del curso los maestros
usaron esos resultados para hacer un
intervalo de confianza del 95% para
estimar la diferencia entre la
proporción de estudiantes que aprueban
en cada modalidad del curso así que esto
de presencial
- p en línea es un intervalo de
confianza del 95% para la diferencia
entre la proporción que aprobó el curso
en modalidad presencial y en línea el
intervalo resultante fue aproximadamente
menos 0.04 a 0.14 y sólo para estar
seguros de que entendemos lo que está
sucediendo esto dice que como estamos
hablando de un intervalo
confianza del 95% el 95% de las veces
que tomamos estas muestras y luego
construimos un intervalo de confianza
para la diferencia de las proporciones
en realidad contendrá la proporción
verdadera quieren usar este intervalo
para probar su hipótesis nula de que las
proporciones verdaderas son iguales
contra su hipótesis alternativa de que
las proporciones verdaderas son
diferentes
supón que todas las condiciones para la
inferencia se satisfacen con base en el
intervalo que sabemos acerca del valor p
correspondiente y de la conclusión para
su prueba pausa en el vídeo y traten de
averiguarlo por su cuenta bien aquí lo
interesante es que vamos a usar un
intervalo de confianza para pensar
acerca de una prueba de hipótesis y
recuerden que en una prueba de hipótesis
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera vamos a suponer esto y hay
otra manera de escribir esto que la
diferencia entre las proporciones
verdaderas presencial y en línea es
igual a cero estas dos son proporciones
equivalentes y en la prueba de hipótesis
vamos a suponer que esta hipótesis nula
es verdadera en la prueba de hipótesis
tradicional estable
su nivel de significancia digamos que
hacemos que ese nivel de significancia
sea del 5% alfa es igual a 5% y ese es
un nivel de significancia típico si la
probabilidad de obtener los resultados
que obtenemos para la diferencia entre
las proporciones muestrales es menor que
5% decimos oye esto es bastante raro
vamos a rechazar la hipótesis nula lo
cual sugerirá la alternativa pero aquí
tenemos algo interesante tenemos un
intervalo de confianza y resulta que si
la suma del intervalo de confianza y del
nivel de significancia es igual al 100%
y estamos llevando a cabo una prueba de
hipótesis bilateral estamos pensando
bueno la hipótesis alternativa no sólo
es que la modalidad presencial sea mayor
que la modalidad en línea o que sea
menor que la modalidad en línea sino que
sean diferentes así que tenemos una
prueba de hipótesis bilateral y en estas
situaciones en realidad podemos hacer
algunas inferencias acerca del valor p a
partir del intervalo de confianza
pensemos lo de esta manera estamos
suponiendo que nuestra hipótesis nula es
verdadera cuando hacemos esta prueba de
hipótesis así
cuando construimos un intervalo de
confianza del 95% esperaríamos que el
95% de los intervalos de confianza
tengan un traslape con el cero de donde
sacamos el cero recuerden que este es un
intervalo de confianza para la
diferencia de las proporciones y la
hipótesis nula es que la diferencia
entre las proporciones verdaderas es
cero así que el 95% de las veces que
hagamos esto si suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera va a haber
un traslape con el 0 otra manera de ver
esto es que el 5% de los intervalos de
confianza no se van a tras la par con el
0 de modo que si estamos en una
situación en la que pasamos por este
proceso para tratar de construir un
intervalo de confianza del 95% y no hay
traslape con la diferencia supuesta de
las proporciones verdaderas de la
hipótesis nula entonces en esta
situación el valor p va a ser menor que
el nivel de significancia del 5% así que
en esta situación rechazaremos la
hipótesis nula 5% de los intervalos de
confianza no se traslapan con el 0 y en
esta primera situación donde el 95% de
los intervalos de confianza
se traslapan con el cero el valor p va a
ser mayor o igual que el nivel alfa y no
podríamos rechazar la hipótesis nula
entonces qué está pasando aquí
bueno el intervalo en realidad incluye
la diferencia entre las proporciones
verdaderas que supusimos con la
hipótesis nula así que eso significa que
al suponer que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera estamos en este primer
escenario 95% de los intervalos de
confianza se traslapan con el 0 p es
mayor o igual que alfa no podemos
rechazar la hipótesis nula este es uno
de los intervalos de confianza del 95%
en donde en realidad con tenemos el
parámetro verdadero que estamos tratando
de estimar así que en esta situación
nuestro valor p va a ser mayor o igual
que nuestro valor alfa que en este caso
es de 5% así que no podemos rechazar la
hipótesis nula y no hay evidencia para
sugerir que hay una diferencia verdadera
entre la tasa de aprobados en la
modalidad presencial y en línea con esto
hemos terminado y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo